Let's talk about thresholding, and
this is an example, I think this might
be taken also from Linda Shapiro.
So the idea is that you're
imaging these cherries, okay, and
the idea is that the background
here is very dark.
Okay?
And a healthy cherry is kind of bright,
all right?
But a bruised part is medium dark.
And what you'd like to
do is be able to say,
do I have a bunch of bruised pixels.
So in this particular one, they've
removed all the black things, but
you see these are the grey scale values,
right?
And you and I look at this, and we say
yep, you know what, here's my threshold,
and this is the number of
pixels that are bruised, and
this is the number of,
of pixels that are good.
And the idea finding a threshold like
that automatically is not trivial.
Generally what you do when you look for
thresholds is you take a histogram
of the intensities, right?
So, this might be, you know,
go from zero to 255,
and this is the number of pixels
that you have in the image.
And the question is, you know,
what are your distributions?
Unlike this one, which had this nice,
clean dis, separation there, this one,
it's a lot more complicated.
Are there two, or are there three?
I think, you know, from my,
from my take, I'd say, oh,
there's three lobes there, all right?
And there's different ways
of trying to do that.
A simple method, this is again,
a long time Otsu's method, it's,
it's a binary visionary method.
It basically says find,
assume that your system is bimodal, and
find the cut off that minimizes
the within group variance.
Okay?
So you're only allowed to draw one line,
and so, and it's weighted by
essentially this, these, these values.
And when you do that,
what's kind of cool about it is you can
do that when it's certainly bi-modal.
When it's actually tri-modal, let's say,
you'll typically pick one of the modes,
all right, and then, you can, look,
do it again, and, you'll cut it again,
and what's kind of nice is when you
slice a mode that shouldn't be sliced,
you'll get a reduction in the variance,
but not very much.
And you can track how much that is.
And it, and the method can be adapted
to do a pretty good job of thresholding
a continuous grayscale into either
a binary or a three valued system.